[Música]
hablamos de nuestra salud en directo
américa con más romeros a la mar
bienvenida muy buen día el martes este
martes que pasó fue el día para un
aborto legal y seguro algo que tiene
grandes consecuencias sobre la salud de
las mujeres mari le pregunto cómo es la
situación en nuestra región en américa
latina pues si te parece raúl empezamos
por revisar cómo son las legislaciones
para entender en qué términos estamos
hablando el aborto sólo es legal en
siete países de américa latina estamos
hablando de uruguay de cuba y más
recientemente por ejemplo argentina
mientras que está prohibido totalmente
en ocho territorios haití por ejemplo en
nicaragua el salvador y en el resto
digamos que está restringido con una
serie de excepciones con el caso
particular de méxico donde es legal en
algunos estados y no lo es en otros
entonces esta es más o menos el panorama
que tenemos en la región mar ahora le
pregunto las consecuencias que tiene
impedir un aborto legal y seguro imagino
que son muchas en las mujeres cierto más
si yo ya te anticipo que son muchas
ahora las vamos a discutir precisamente
entrevistamos almudena rodríguez ella es
de la asociación de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de cataluña esto fue lo
que nos dijo escuchamos lo el hecho de
que esté penalizado en muchos países del
mundo hace que las mujeres tengan que
recurrir a abortos clandestinos
abortos clandestinos
que normalmente no se ejercitan con
todas las garantías médicas de calidad
bajo supervisión de profesionales y ahí
se pone en riesgo la vida de las mujeres
y de las personas gestantes es decir
raúl que la gente no deja de abortar
porque es prohibido entonces bueno
hablemos igualmente si te parece de qué
tipos de aborto hay una para romper un
poco el tabú que existe alrededor de
esto y también para entender bien cuáles
son sus riesgos hay dos tipos de aborto
por un lado es el farmacológico que
consiste en tomar una pastilla que
interrumpe el embarazo se recomienda en
las etapas más tempranas del embarazo
precisamente y se considera que tiene
poco riesgo aunque siempre debe hacerse
bajo supervisión médica por otro lado
está el aborto quirúrgico
últimamente la técnica que más se
prefiere es una especie de técnica de
succión es decir que se aspira todo lo
que hay dentro del útero interrumpir el
embarazo pero también existe la técnica
del legrado que es más riesgosa que la
oms de la organización mundial de la
salud de hecho ya la considera obsoleta
y que consiste como en raspar las
paredes del útero esto sí se hace bajo
unas condiciones saludables y con buen
acompañamiento no tiene mayor riesgo
pero si se hace de manera insegura puede
entrañar muchísimos riesgos estamos
hablando por ejemplo de hemorragias
infecciones daños en el aparato
reproductor en los órganos internos de
las mujeres y de las personas gestantes
y todo esto teniendo en cuenta además
que en los países donde el aborto está
totalmente penalizado una mujer no puede
acudir a centros de salud en caso de que
algo vaya mal porque corre el riesgo de
ser judicial izada o de ser penalizada
de alguna manera marc pero ahora vamos a
ponerle un poco de cifras a toda esta
problemática de salud exacto hagamos de
eso mira cada año hay 7 millones de
mujeres que terminan hospitalizadas por
incurrir en estas prácticas de abortos
inseguros pero en américa latina
particularmente donde sólo el 10 por
ciento de las mujeres viven en
territorios donde tienen acceso a aborto
en este en américa latina al 75% o sea
tres cuartas partes de todos los abortos
que se realizan son inseguros con todos
los riesgos que estábamos hablando y de
todas las muertes maternas que existen
en la región el 10 por ciento está
provocada precisamente por este tipo de
prácticas estamos hablando de muertes
que podrían ser evitables con el mayor
acceso a métodos anticonceptivos con una
información mayor con menos
estigmatización también y sobre todo
permitiendo que la interrupción de los
embarazos se puedan hacer de maneras
seguras es verdad lo que usted dice marc
y además también entender que pues
tampoco las mujeres usan esto como un
método anticonceptivo porque muchas
personas que están en contra del aborto
pues esa es una de como sus lemas para
estar en contra de esto que pues nadie
en su sano juicio va a usar esta
práctica como un método anticonceptivo
más pero entonces significa que
legalizar el aborto es también
y recurrimos a menos muertes mujeres no
mira de hecho no necesariamente es decir
obviamente legalizar el aborto ayuda de
algunas maneras pero siguen habiendo es
una mala noticia sin habiendo barreras
que hacen que las mujeres no
necesariamente accedan a abortos de
seguros aunque sean legales almudena
precisamente nos puso el ejemplo de
españa y esto fue lo que nos dijo en
españa' en muchísimas comunidades
autónomas en muchísimas ciudades
provincias no es posible ejercer una
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo no
hay centros hospitalarios no hay
hospitales no hay clínicas donde puedas
ejercer una interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo y por lo tanto te obligan a es
la parte a otros lugares del país no hay
información de calidad no hay
información adaptada al no hay una
información libre de estigmas y por lo
tanto cuando una mujer
a realizar una interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo le cuesta mucho acceder a
la información de donde no puede
realizar como qué procedimiento debe de
seguir claro es decir que el propio
sistema de salud a veces no está
preparado tampoco para brindar esta
asistencia no también por ejemplo con
los objetores de conciencia y centros
enteros que se oponen a este tipo de
prácticas y también pues la falta de
información de los mismos profesionales
de la salud hay un largo camino delante
de nosotros largo camino mar vamos a ver
entonces cómo se desarrolla sobre todo
en américa latina'